خلال موسم دراما رمضان العام الماضي شهد
الجمهور السوداني الثنائيه متناغمه خطفت
الانظار ونالت الاشادات الفنان السوداني
احمد الفنانه وكمال معروفه بروبي
ظهر في مسلسل سكه الضيعه وفاز بقلوب
المشاهدين من خلال ثنائيه رشا وعبادي
ولكن الكوميديه التي اذيعت اولى حلقاتها
على منصه التواصل في اكتوبر الماضي
وتتناول الخلافات الزوجيه في قالب طريف
رؤى
[موسيقى]
احمد انت مغني وملحن وشاعر وروبي طبيبه
اسنان مع كل هذه المفارقه نجحتما في اول
عمل درامي لكما كسناي شو سر هذا النجاح
ممكن تكون صدفه
بعداك ممكن تقول لي السرو ممكن يكون
التوفيق من رب العالمين
فالحمد لله يعني الناس من سكر الضياع قبل
الدور بتاعنا مع بعض
اليوم
يا احمد
ههه
المسلسل الجديد ان شاء الله اسمه زاندا ان
شاء الله في رمضان لا يقيل ان شاء الله
جمالا عن سكه طيب العمل تضمن يا روبي ويا
احمد بعض المشاهد الرومانسيه واعتبر انه
شيء جديد في الدراما السودانيه كيف
تلقيتما ردود الافعال على ذلك كيف اعطيتهم
على الموضوع
رومانسيه لكن طبعا احنا شويه كده
ان انا الخجل وعندنا حدود يعني في الحاجات
دي لكن ممكن في البدايات الناس شويه ان
احنا تعرضنا مثلا كان فرد فعل همم في ردود
فعل كانت جميله
انه احنا عاملين حدود شديد يعني في
الرومانسيه
في ناس جدلات وفي ناس ما قبلت لكن
الاغلبيه كانت انه هي حابه تشوف همم برامج
جديده حابه ان السوداني نقدر يعبر عن
حاجاته من جوه الحب بالنسبه للطرف الاول
والطرف يعني همم الاغلبيه حبت الحاجه دي
يعني في التجربه الاخيره
بتكون مغلفه كده بالكلمات شويه بتكون همم
جاده قولي احمد مثلا اكتب لكن ان شاء الله
ده هيكون الطبيعي روبي روبي انت عمرك
استغليتي فرصه التمثيل مع احمد لك نفسي عن
غضبك وزعلك الحقيقي منه في الحياه مثلا
كان في مشهد غضب يلا نستغل الفرصه عم
بنمثل بغضب اكثر ههه
استغليت الفلوس عشان بيناتنا مثلا حاجه
وكده لو هو في العموم انا في العموم انا
باشوف انه التمثيل بالنسبه لك روبي متنفس
يعني مثلا كنت باقول لاحمد انه مثلا نفسي
مثلا اعمل شخصيات مثلا سيكوباتك كده يعني
همم امراض نفسيه حاجاتكم ملكات كده عشان
انا في الحياه ما باقدر اكون كده في
التمثيل بالنسبه لهم متنفس للحاجات دي
اللي ما بيقدر يكون شريره مثلا في الحياه
نفسي اكون كده اعمل ادوار كده يعني فيها
شعر وحاج كده فبالنسبه للمتنفس لكل حاجه
في الحياه ما بالضروره للشيخ او كده
وبعدين احمد يعني ههه قعد يضايقني ههه
طيب احمد شهدناك همم شاركت في كتابته
الحلو غناء تتر سكر ضايع لماذا لا تشارك
بصوتك الجميل في اعمال الدراميه اخرى اه
انا لي 17 سنه بغني وبكتي وبالحين وكده
فالفتره الجايه دي صراحه انا
ضاغط اكثر على التمثيل يعني التجربه
الدراميه على اساس انه حابه اغير شويه
يعني انا ليس 17 سنه بغني فما بحس انه في
جديد لكن هسه الجديد بالنسبه للدرامه همم
حاسس انه في قبول اكبر في حب اكبر فااه
هضغط شويه على الدراما الفتره الجايه دي
يعني
[موسيقى]